in this sequence of segments we review
some mathematical background that will
be useful at various places in this
course most of what is covered with the
exception of the last segment is
material that you may have seen before
but this could still be an opportunity
to refresh some of these concepts I
should say that this is intended to be
just a refresher our coverage is not
going to be complete in any sense
what we will talk about is set various
definitions related to sets and some
basic properties including the Morgan's
laws we will talk about what a sequence
is and what it means for a sequence to
converge to something we will talk about
infinite series and as an example we
will look at the geometric series then
we will talk about some subtleties that
arise when you have sums of terms that
are indexed with multiple indices and
finally probably the most sophisticated
part will be a discussion of countable
versus uncountable sets countable sets
are like the integers uncountable sets
are like the real line and they are
fundamentally different and this
fundamental difference reflects itself
in two fundamentally different
probabilistic models models that involve
discrete experiments and outcomes versus
models that involve continues outcomes